now Congress I have the high privilege
and distinct honor of presenting to you
His Excellency jens stoltenberg the
secretary-general of the North Atlantic
Treaty Organization
[Applause]
madam speaker mr. vice president
honorable members of the United States
Congress ladies and gentlemen I am
really truly honored I'm grateful for
the privilege of addressing you all
today and to represent the 29 members of
the NATO alliance seventy years ago
tomorrow NATO's founding treaty was
signed in this great city and on that
day
President Truman said we hope to create
a shield against aggression and the fear
of aggression a bulwark which will
permit us to get on with the real
business of government and society the
business of achieving a fuller and
happier life for all our citizens
our alliance was created by people who
have who had lived through two
devastating World Wars they knew only
too well the horror the suffering and
the human and material cost of war they
were determined that this should never
happen again
and they were also determined to stand
up to the expansion of the Soviet Union
which was taking control over its
neighbors crushing democracies and
oppressing their people so they founded
NATO with a clear purpose to preserve
peace and to safeguard freedom and with
an ironclad commitment by all members of
the Alliance to protect each other
they made a solemn promise one for all
and all for one
this commitment has served us well peace
has been preserved freedom maintained
yes
allies have been involved in conflicts
in different parts of the world and
allies have suffered the pain of
terrorist attacks but no NATO ally has
been attacked by another country the
Cold War ended without a shot being
fired in Europe and we have experienced
an unprecedented period of peace so the
NATO alliance is not only the longest
lasting alliance in history it is the
most successful alliance in history
ever since that founding our treaty or
alliance in 1949 every Congress every
American president your men and women in
uniform and the people of the United
States of America have been staunch
supporters of NATO America has been the
backbone of our alliance it has been
fundamental to European security and for
our freedom we would not have the
peaceful and prosperous Europe we see
today without the sacrifice and the
commitment of the United States for your
enduring support I thank you today
so NATO has been good for Europe but
NATO has also been good for the United
States
the strength of a nation is not only
measured by the site the size of its
economy or the number of its soldiers
but but also by the number of its
friends and to NATO the United States
has more friends and allies than any of
the power this has made the United
States stronger safer and more secure
madam Speaker mr. vice president it is
good to have friends
yes the ants I flew over the Atlantic I
looked out of my window at the ocean
below the great ocean that noise between
our two continents the Atlantic does not
divide us it unites us it binds us
together and for Norwegians like me the
Atlantic Ocean defines who we are indeed
it was a Norseman Leif Eriksson who was
the first European to reach American
shores
almost a thousand years ago in fact more
people would know if you hadn't left so
quickly and decided not to tell anyone
about it for adventures like Leif
Eriksson the Atlantic Ocean was never a
barrier rather it was a great blue
bridge to new lands and new
possibilities for millions of Europeans
it has been a bridge to freedom
sanctuary and hope my grandparents were
among them my mother was born in
Paterson New Jersey
[Applause]
and I lived part of my childhood in San
Francisco
so this has given me a sense of kinship
with this wonderful country a kinship
that has only grown throughout my life
for instance I remember well during the
Cold War when I was a conscript in an
original army our forces were trained
and equipped to hold the line that we
knew that we could not take on the might
of the Soviet Union alone and always
actually boring the Soviet Union was
pouring salt into the Cold War but we
also knew that we were not alone we knew
that if needed
our NATO allies led by the United States
would soon be there with us we enjoyed a
level of security that only our
transatlantic alliance could ride so
thanks to NATO as a young man during the
Cold War I felt safe and that says
something about the strength of our
alliance madam speaker mr. vice
president members of Congress at the
entrance to the NATO headquarters in
Belgium
there are two monuments one a piece of
the Berlin wall designed to keep people
in and ideas out it failed it failed
it's failed because the ideas and the
values of those who built it were less
compelling and less powerful than ours
because we as NATO were resolute we
stood together and would not back down
the other monument is a twisted steel
beam from the North Tower of the World
Trade Center a memorial to the ordinary
people going about their business on an
ordinary day when the unthinkable
happened a memorial to the 2977 people
who lost their lives on 9/11 a reminder
how all NATO allies stood with the
United States in its hour of need
[Applause]
one monument is a symbol of freedom the
other a symbol of solidarity both are
symbols of NATO who we are and what we
stand for what so many our brave men and
women have fought for and sometimes died
for it but not in vain and not alone the
men and women of our armed forces have
served together
you
and I pay tribute to you and to also
serve in the defense of Edom
there is no higher cost and freedom and
in these two monuments we see the
challenges we have overcome as an
alliance we deterred the Soviet Union
during the Cold War stopped Wars and
atrocities in the Balkans fought
terrorism from Afghanistan to the Middle
East welcomed the newly free nations of
Central and Eastern Europe into our
alliance helping to spread democracy
peace and prosperity an NATO's door
remains open this year the Republic of
North Macedonia signed the accession
protocol and with your support
and with your support North Macedonia
will soon become the 30th member of our
alliance so what started in 1949 with 12
members has proven a powerful force for
peace an alliance that others strive to
join showing the historic success of
NATO but as you all know success in the
past is not a guarantee of success in
the future and we have to be frank
questions are being asked on both sides
of the Atlantic about the strength of
our partnership and yes there are
differences we are an alliance of many
different nations with different
geography history and political parties
Republicans and Democrats conservatives
and labour independence greens and many
more this is democracy open discussions
and different views is not a sign of
weakness it is a sign of strength
so we we should not be surprised when we
see differences between our countries
today there are disagreements on issues
such as trade energy climate change and
there are nuclear deal these are serious
issues with serious disagreements but we
should remember that we had already our
disagreements also before the Suez
Crisis in 1956 the French withdrawal
from military cooperation NATO in 1966
or the Iraq war in 2003 which was
strongly supported by some allies and
equally strongly opposed by others the
strength of NATO is that despite our
differences we have always been able to
unite around our core tasks to defend
each other protect each other and to
keep our people safe
we have overcome our disagreements in
the past and we must overcome our
differences now because we will need our
alliance even more in the future we face
unprecedented challenges challenges no
one nation can face alone the global
balance of power is shifting the fight
against terrorism is a generational
fight we all only just seen the
beginning of the threats in cyberspace
artificial intelligence quantum
computing and big data could change the
nature of conflict more fundamentally
than the Industrial Revolution and we
will need to continue to deal with a
more assertive Russia in 2014 Russia
illegally annexed Crimea the first time
in Europe that one country had taken
part or not by force since World War two
and we see a pattern of Russian behavior
including a massive military buildup
from the Arctic to the Mediterranean and
from the Black Sea to the Baltic the use
of military-grade nerve agent in a key
kingdom support for Assad's murderous
regime in Syria consistent cyber attacks
on NATO allies and partners targeting
everything from Parliament's to power
grids sophisticated disinformation
campaigns and attempts to interfere in
democracy itself
NATO has responded with the biggest
reinforcements to our collective defense
in decades for the first time we had
combat troops deployed in the east of
our alliance we have increased the
readiness of forces tripled the size of
the NATO Response Force modernized our
command structure bolstered our cyber
defenses and we have stepped up our
support to our close partners Georgia
and Ukraine seven nations with a certain
right to choose their own path
[Applause]
we M we do all of this not to provoke
the conflict but you prevent the
conflict and to preserve peace not to
fight but to deter not to attack but to
defend there is no contradiction between
the terrans defense and dialogue we do
not want to isolate Russia we strive for
a better relationship with Russia but
even without a better relationship
we still need to manage a difficult one
so we need to talk and we do talk to
reduce risks to avoid incidents
accidents and miscalculations we also
need dialogue in order to work for arms
control my generation was shaped by the
deployment of thousands of nuclear
missiles in Europe in the 1980s missiles
capable of destroying our cities and
killing millions of people in moments
thanks to the vision and leadership of
President Reagan and premier Gorbachev
the iron age treaty put an end to all
these weapons
but today they are back russia has
deployed new missiles in Europe they are
mobile hotter detect nuclear capable cut
the warning time to just minutes and
reduce the threshold for the use of
nuclear weapons in an armed conflict
NATO's position is united and clear
Russia is in violation of the INF treaty
there are no new American missiles in
Europe but there are new Russian
missiles I continue to call on Russia to
return to compliance with the INF treaty
but so far Russia has taken no steps to
do so and time is running out we do we
do not want a new arms race we do not
want a new cold war but we must not be
naive an agreement that is only
respected by one side will not keep us
safe so we so we must also prepare for a
world without the INF treaty we will be
measured and coordinated we will not
mirror what Russia is doing NATO has no
intention of deploying land-based
nuclear missiles in Europe but NATO will
always take the necessary steps to
provide credible and effective
deterrence
[Applause]
madam speaker mr. vice president the
fight against terrorism also demands our
collective effort the attacks on 9/11
made that clear NATO's response to those
attacks was swift within 24 hours and
for the first and only time in our
history we invoked article 5 of The
Washington treaty The Collected defense
Clause which states an armed attack
against one shall be considered an
attack against them all so 9/11 was not
only an attack on the United States but
against all NATO allies within days NATO
aircraft were patrolling American skies
and in the wake of 9/11 NATO soldiers
went to fight side-by-side in
Afghanistan to prevent that country from
every gain becoming a safe haven for
terrorists who could attack us here at
home over the years hundreds of
thousands of troops from Europe and
Canada have served in Afghanistan over a
thousand have paid the ultimate price
and many more have been seriously
wounded we honor their service and their
sacrifice
NATO remains in Afghanistan today to
fight terrorism and to train Afghan
forces our goal is not to stay there
forever we should not stay any longer
than is necessary we went in together we
will decide our future presence together
and when the time comes we will leave
together
NATO fully supports the peace process
you must pave the way for Afghan
reconciliation they can only be peace if
if Afghanistan stays free from
international terrorists and for peace
to be sustainable it must build on our
achievements NATO has created the
conditions for social and economic
progress bringing education and human
rights to women and girls
[Applause]
they're rights must be preserved NATO is
not only fighting terrorism in
Afghanistan we are also part of the
global coalition to defeat Isis the
Coalition has made remarkable progress
once Isis controlled an area roughly the
size of Virginia they and they imposed
the twisted either ideology or millions
they beheaded people burned people alive
and traded women as sex slaves we should
never forget their brutality and thanks
to American leadership and our
collective effort we have stopped this
brutality and millions of people have
been liberated
but our work is not done
that is why NATO is stepping up our
training of Iraqi forces so they can
better defend their country and make
sure Isis can never return this is also
why NATO supports our partners in the
Middle East and North Africa helping
them to build up their intelligence
services border security cyber security
and special operation forces training
local forces and building local capacity
are among the best weapons we have in
the fight against terrorism prevention
is better than intervention
[Applause]
madam Speaker
mr. vice president some of you here
today will have been directly affected
by terrorism you may have lost friends
and loved ones you know the reality of
terrorism I know it too I was Prime
Minister of Norway on the 22nd of July
2011 a date that will live in infamy in
the history of my country that day a
terrorist detonated a bomb outside my
office killing eight people and injuring
many more he then went to the island of
Utah where young people were enjoying a
summer camp
he killed a further 69 people most of
them teenagers with their whole lives
ahead of them it was the darkest day in
Norway since the Second World War
it was the darkest day of my life
terrorism comes in many forms
some perpetrators misuse religion others
misuse political ideology they claim to
be different from each other fighting
for different causes but they are all
the same they believe in hatred violence
and killing innocent men women and
children they are nothing more than
cowards
terrorists attack our freedom our values
and our way of life our answer must be
more openness and more democracy our
values will prevail freedom will prevail
over oppression tolerance over
intolerance and love will always prevail
over hate
I see this in the flowers laid outside
the mosques in Christchurch New Zealand
I see this in the lives led by the young
survivors of the attacks in Norway and I
see this in New York and Washington to
indomitable cities cities that were not
intimidated not defeated but which rose
stronger than ever from the horror of
that September morning madam Speaker
mr. vice president NATO is strong lines
but to remain a strong Alliance NATO
must be a fair alliance in an ideal
world we would not need to spend any
money on defense but we do not live in
an ideal world freedom has enemies and
they need to be deterred and if the
terrans fails we need to fight Hitler
could not have been stopped with
peaceful protest Stalin could not have
been deterred with words Isis could not
have been defeated with dialogue future
enemies of freedom may choose violence
again our desire for a peaceful world is
simply not enough we must act and invest
to make it so
[Applause]
NATO allies must spend more on defense
this has been the clear message from
President Trump and this message is
having a real impact
of the years of reducing defense budgets
all our lies have stopped the cuts and
all our lies have increased the defense
spending before they were cutting
billions now they're adding billions in
just lost two years European Alice and
Canada have spent an additional forty 1
billion dollars on defense by the end of
next year that figure will rise to 100
billion
this is making Natal stronger
that money will allow us to invest in
new capabilities our armed forces need
including advanced fighter aircraft
attack helicopters missile defense and
surveillance drones this is good for
Europe and it's good for America
America's NATO allies provide important
capabilities including tens of thousands
of intelligence personnel and cyber
experts giving the United States better
eyes and ears where you need them from
tracking submarines in your tech to
taking down the cyber networks of Isis
and Europe provide provides the US with
a platform to project power around the
world last year I was in Fort Worth
Texas
and yeah and I saw and I saw our
industry so many NATO allies are working
together to produce next generation
strike fighter aircraft NATO has always
had a technological edge to keep that
edge
we must innovate and capitalize on the
ingenuity our industries and our best
minds on both sides of the Atlantic this
will continue to provide us with
advanced capabilities and create jobs in
the United States Canada and Europe
so our transatlantic bond is not just
about security it is also about
prosperity it is not by chance that
article 2 of the Washington treaty
encourages economic collaboration
between our nation's Europe and America
has long been by far each other's
largest trading partners creating
millions of jobs or on both sides of the
Atlantic generating more than 3 billion
dollars a day in trade injecting
trillions of dollars into our economies
there is more wealth greater health
better education and more happiness
thanks to the bond between our two
compliments
madam speaker mr. vice president the
ultimate expression of burden-sharing
is that we stand together fight together
and sometimes die together I have listed
all in National Cemetery to pay tribute
to all those American soldiers who have
given their lives many of them in
defense of Europe to world wars and the
cold war made it clear how important
America is to the security of Europe and
equally that peace and stability in
Europe is important to the United States
our alliance has not lost it for 70
years out of a sense of nostalgia or a
sentiment
NATO lost because it is in the national
interest of each and every one of our
nation's together we represent 1 billion
people we are half of the world's
economic might and half of the world's
military might when we stand together we
are stronger than any potential
challenges economically politically and
militarily
[Applause]
we need this collective strength because
we will face new threats and we have
seen so many times before how difficult
it is to predict the future we were not
able to predict the fall of the Berlin
Wall the 9/11 attacks or the rise of
Isis or Russia's illy illegal annexation
of Crimea since we cannot foresee the
future we have to be prepared for the
unforeseen we need a strategy to deal
with uncertainty we have one
that strategy is NATO
as strong and agile NATO reduces risks
and enables us to deal with surprises
when they happen and they will happen
NATO is the most successful alliance in
history because we have always been able
to change as the world changes and
because despite our differences we are
united in our commitment to each other
NATO is an alliance over sovereign
nations united by democracy liberty and
the rule of law by a person's right to
live their life in the pursuit of
happiness free from oppression values
that lie at the heart of the United
States and at the heart of NATO as
President Eisenhower NATO's first
supreme Allied commander said we are
concerned not only with the protection
of territory but with the defense of a
way of life Europe and North America are
not separated by the Atlantic Ocean we
are united by it and just like Atlantic
NATO unites our continents our nations
and our people it has done so for 70
years and today we must do everything in
our power to maintain that unity for
future generations because combat may we
are stronger and safer when we stand
together madam speaker mr. vice
president it is good to have friends
[Applause]
[Applause]